from the start of 2017 the regulations
around small heated pools such as spa
pools and hot tubs have changed and as
long as they meet the following criteria
they no longer need to be fenced mostly
to fit into this category they need to
have an area of follow'd meter square or
less and they need to be designed for
therapeutic or recreational use and then
it needs to have a suitable cover it
must restrict the entry of children when
covered be able to withstand a
reasonably foreseeable load be able to
be readily returned to the closed
position and have signage indicating its
child safety features every wall of the
pool must be higher than 760 millimeters
from the ground and they must be
difficult to climb the tap or hose that
is used to fill the pool must be fitted
with a backflow preventer these
inexpensive devices stop water being
sucked back into the mains water supply
finally you'll need to register your
pool with the council for free will come
along and check everything is correct
give you one of these safety stickers
and then you're good to go
[Music]
you
[Music]